(ominous music)
- Is planning to do like, 30
minutes of questioning you
and then throw it out to the floor.
- You know, I love all my
friends and 40 to 80 who
look down on him like who do you think
created this structure
that these young kids
are popping out of?
- (laughs) I made them.
- Yeah, you created it.
- So I understand--
- Such an interesting point.
You know exactly how they got there.
- Do you come to London often?
- We have an office here, yeah.
Even the wine thing, I
wanted to be the person
that they could've
pointed to when they were
at the French Laundry and
saying to the sommelier,
"Fuck you."
The most powerful people that like,
the people that walk around
here with eight-figure salaries
will go to a restaurant and crumble
in the face of a wine list.
- Yeah.
- And I was always so fascinated by,
and it's kind of like art.
Like, it's so funny how I look at art.
I know nothing about that world.
But any time I even, by
accident, stumble into it
at an event or things of that
nature, I watch people talk,
and there's just such an
inner smirk that I have.
I'm like, "I know who you are."
It's power, but around a subjective thing.
That's why, you know what's funny,
it's the first time I ever realized that.
It's the same way I feel about
commercials and creative.
In my advertising world,
my biggest problem is
there are people who
try to impose their will
on something that's subjective.
Which is exactly what I didn't
like about the wine world.
Fuck, I never really put
two and two together.
- It's um--
- And so, like parents wanna blame
Instagram and social media.
What they need to blame is themselves.
Like, if you didn't micromanage
the fuck out of every hour
of every day from four to nine,
maybe they would have a chance.
I want you to level up what
I'm actually talking about,
which is why do we get to have peace?
And why do we have to get continuity
financially or economically?
Like, why are we not
supposed to be a generation
that goes through a great depression?
Thank you, nice to meet you.
- See you.
- See you guys.
- See ya.
- Hello gang.
- How you doing?
- Really well.
Hey Alexa.
Such a pleasure, thank you.
How are you, very good.
Alexa stop.
I think the bigger question
is what do you want to happen?
Are you here to be a non-profit
social justice thing?
Do you wanna make a trillion dollars?
So, let's go about it a different way.
I think too many people go this route.
I'm gonna spend two years building this
and then I can go to BMW or
Manchester United or Booths
and get money from them to be a sponsor.
I would argue that you
may want to think about it
a different way.
You can get the same money
from those people right now
by showing them that you
can do this kind of content.
And so, I think a lot of
people in your position wait
and try to do a business model
that's based on advertising
and I think you can start tomorrow
and build a business based on service.
Do something about it.
I am being very thoughtful about this.
(laughs)
(men chattering)
Love it, take care guys.
Love it.
First of all, in general, I
love this entire campaign.
But more importantly,
this means a lot to me.
I'm gonna completely rock it.
Thank you so much for thinking about me
and making this for me.
How cool is this?
Right?
Captain Optimism, this
is just a smart campaign.
- Smart.
- Super smart.
Well that's why I wanna buy brands, right?
Because, like, for me, you know, hello.
It's all right.
- Hey.
- Hi.
- You know what, I launched a book today.
- Get outta town.
Congratulations.
Morning Instagram,
me and D-Rock walking
the streets of London.
Decided to go live for
like a second or two
every morning now 'cause I
know it's morning in the U.S.
and just I don't know, shoot
like, 40 seconds right?
That'd be cool, right?
Like, I see the pole.
40 seconds of like some good shit.
So here's my 40 seconds of good shit.
Judgment.
Judgment blows.
I hate how many people judge other people
without having all the context.
Every time you fucking judge,
you make yourself vulnerable.
Like, you don't fucking
know what's going on
in somebody's fucking
home, you fucking asshole.
So stop fucking judging people
when you don't know shit.
But most of all, stop judging yourself.
'Cause when you stop judging yourself,
it opens up a world of possibilities.
You start doing real shit.
So please stop judging yourself.
'Cause guess what?
I got breaking news for you.
Everybody else fucking sucks too.
I really like this whole concept
of not putting something
dead inside of you.
Like, there's something that really
resonates with me for some reason.
- [Man] Plants and
animals, or just animals?
- Animals.
Moreso than plants.
But honestly, that's the
first time I've even debated
through my mind like plants.
By the way, I don't
disagree with that either.
I don't know.
Commerce is a huge part
of where we're going.
I will remind you one more time.
I only have this company to buy brands.
(hip hop music)
(people chattering)
I think patience is one of
the great secret weapons
of my success.
- [Man] 'Cause you look
like you aren't patient.
But you are in the long-term,
but in the short-term,
you're very quick, right?
- That's right.
Micro speed, macro patience.
Clouds and dirt.
- Okay, so what will you
advise our Polish viewers
and readers about patience?
- Look, everybody's
always trying to prove,
the reason I'm patient, is I'm
not trying to prove anything
to anybody else but myself.
And I have my whole life to do that.
When you're not patient, you're
worried about other people.
You wanna be successful, so
your mom was proven wrong.
So your brother was proven wrong.
So you proved, you're
doing it for somebody,
your lack of lack of patience.
You're not patient 'cause
you need more money,
'cause you have to buy a BMW,
so that you look successful
to your classmates.
Not smart, not smart.
And so, patience goes hand in hand
with being inside your own self.
I'm so thankful that I only
guide within my own self.
Otherwise, I'd be living my
life in a very different way.
(people chattering)
And I genuinely think we're just starting.
And we've been doing it by selling
something people don't believe in.
Just wanna remind everybody
that we're the fastest growing
agency in this generation and
one of the fastest all time.
And we've done it unlike
the two or three others
in the history that have been so great.
Whether it's a wide inner
or, they were great,
or Droga, at the craft that they knew.
They left, and like they came with,
we were started by a kid
who had a liquor store
and kid out of college and
sold something nobody wants.
We, today, mainly still
sell strategy and execution
around things that most of
our clients barely believe in.
Do you understand how good
of a situation we're in?
The most thoughtful people
are awfully worried.
Which is good.
They got shit to do.
Later.
(people chatting)
- It's cool.
- 2017, right?
Dude, honestly, I just feel like the way
you've impacted my life,
no other human being has
had the ability to do that.
And for that I want to thank you.
I'm so grateful that you even
had, like, a moment to even,
I won't take too much of your time.
I know you're a very busy dude.
But thanks dude.
And I think so much of what you've said
has come true for me.
So much of what I've learned from you
wouldn't have been possible
if I didn't hear that.
- Why did it break through to you?
- So I'll be honest.
I think that, as you said,
the whole motivational thing
is quite cliched now and at the end
there's a cool attraction
to sell something.
It's become quite generic
and it doesn't work anymore.
But with you I was waiting like (laughs),
he's gonna sell me something.
- When's the shoe dropping? (laughs)
- But like, you never tried
to sell anything, dude.
If anything, you over-delivered.
You gave information that was
so actionable and applicable.
It just hit right where it had to.
And for me, I wasn't used to that.
Like, I'm around a lot of creative people,
but the way you articulate
certain information,
I was just like, "Wow,
this dude is insane.
"The wealth of knowledge he has.
"It's really crazy."
And thank you dude.
Thank you.
It feels like I know you, man.
- (laughs) I get it.
- Like, I saw you wearing
this top on your Insta story.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like, yeah man, like oh dude.
But thank you.
- So what are you doing now?
- The essential brand of what
I do is I'm a content creator
and a stand-up comedian.
In a nutshell, I was
making content online--
- What we're gonna move
into now is something
that my wife and I discovered years ago
that made all of our dinners far more fun.
Which is one conversation.
So, I'll start and throw
out the first theme,
which I'll start
brainstorming as we do intros.
But we'll go into one convo and kind of,
what I get blown away by in
this format and what, you know,
what I think some of you, if
you haven't done it exactly
in the one convo with this size,
is there's a lot of IP exchanged,
there's a lot of value exchanged.
When the mobile phone came
along, especially the iPhone,
I basically decided the next
biggest companies in the world
were gonna be built on top of it.
Which, at the time, all
of us professionals,
for the most part, that
was a little far-fetched.
I genuinely believed that billion dollar,
and even trillion dollar, what
I was projecting at the time,
companies would be built as just apps.
And I think the Wazes and
the Instagrams and Spotifys
have proven that thesis right.
I believe, that's fun to have you here,
I believe that the voice
platform's gonna be the next one.
That the products and services built
on top of the voice devices,
whether, in speaker form,
or just native, are gonna
be dramatically bigger
than they think.
In that, and that thinking
that I've been doing
for about two years, something
incredibly interesting
has evolved to me.
Which is, holy shit.
The only thing that's
gonna be left is brand.
In a world where there's no friction
to make your buying decision,
and completely different
than the toll booth
that Google was, if I say to my device,
"I need peanut butter,"
Amazon, Google, Apple,
whomever wins the game, or
my personal, at-home game,
is going to either send me
their private label peanut butter,
or they're gonna charge
an awful lot of money
in the affiliate or first result
to be the default peanut butter.
Which means, I better say, "Jiffy,"
or I better not say shampoo,
or whatever the hell you wanna sell
and on and on and on and on.
My question to you is, when, not if,
you are buying an
enormous amount of things
through voice in seven years,
which brand will you always say
instead of the generic product?
What is your favorite
brand that you could never
imagine saying, for example,
I would say, "Cereal."
I think I would say limo or
black car but would I say Uber?
I don't even know,
that's why I'm actually
gonna go the other way.
Anthony, I'm gonna send it to you.
What is the brand, I'm
gonna think about mine,
cause I really don't have one.
I'm trying to think,
Captain Crunch cereal.
- [Man] Well there you go.
What cereal, I was like--
- I would go with Captain Crunch cereal.
But I will tell you, oh
no, I'm not wearing them.
But I will tell you, as I obviously,
and I'm forcing myself
subconsciously to buy
a lot more things on Alexa than I think
I normally would have 'cause I'm curious.
But I did something that
I didn't think I would do,
I bought jeans on Amazon through Alexa,
and didn't care what brand came.
And, to give you the punch
line, they were Diesel.
I had never bought a pair
of Diesel jeans before.
If you sat here, if we
did this a year ago,
I would've not thought
that jeans was a category
I actually didn't care about.
And that's what got me thinking.
I'm like, huh, I would've
thought this is like privacy.
I love what people say
versus what they do.
I would've said, "Jeans is
a category I care about."
I actually think about
the jeans that I buy
versus the bottled water
which I definitely would not care about.
But yet, in my actions, I
bought three pairs of jeans
'cause I just needed 'em.
And I went for the convenience.
So, Anthony, what would
definitely be the brand?
Because you love your
deodorants so much, your cereal.
If it was just one,
if everything else was just commoditized,
what would be the one brand
that would come out of
your mouth as, "Alexa,
"send me Heineken."
Not beer.
(hip hop music)